dans cette banlieue paisible bienvenue
chez paul est salie il y à 13 ans il
adoptait benjamin un petit bébé blond
c'était le pitch un peu fou du film
il a déjà les yeux en salles en 2010 cet
ensemble un peu surtout à la main
monsieur la famille à l'eau car
provenant du service pour une série en
prime time en six épisodes avec toujours
la double casquette de lucien jean
baptiste à la fois comédien et
réalisateur confiance mais bon depuis
combien 54 jours continus en ayant un
programme à la télé comme de ce type
familial à 21h pour moi voilà je
trouvais qu'il était intéressant de
pouvoir communiquer au plus grand nombre
rentré chez les français voilà ça ça
pourrait être un titre de de ça pour
être le titre de la série une famille
française voilà j'avais vraiment par le
prisme de cette famille envie de
m'adresser aux français mais en 13 ans
il y a eu quelques changements
forcément à faire le lien parce qu'elle
n'en voit pas tous les jours des poupées
noires des mois notre enfant adoptif
notre enfant est un adolescent et on a
eu un autre enfant également
naturellement comme on dit et donc
benjamin le bébé tout blond qui a
maintenant 14 ans est à la recherche de
sa vraie mère ce qui n'a pas compris que
sa vraie mère c'était moi au delà de
l'adoption il sera question du lien
familial de la parentalité mais pas
seulement
à travers cette fiction le réalisateur
martiniquais veut montrer la société
dans toute sa diversité
voilà ce qui a séduit france télé c'est
vraiment notre souci de représenter la
france comme elle est on est
actuellement aussi en post production
d'une série qui se passe aux antilles
qui s'appelle tropiques criminelle avec
sonia rolland on a en tournage en ce
moment d'une série aussi qui se passe à
la réunion
voilà donc on a on a cette volonté là de
effectivement c'est une préoccupation
très importante pour nous pour
représenter la france telle qu'elle
il a déjà tes yeux avait réuni près d'un
million 400 mille spectateurs au cinéma
la série sera diffusée courant 2020 sur
france 2